The broadcast is now starting. All
attendees are in listen only mode.
Hey everyone. Good morning. Welcome to
this educational presentation of
practical applications of order flow
trading. And you know, thanks for taking
the time out of your Saturday morning to
come join me today. You know, my name is
Michael Valtos and if you're new to my
presentations, I'm the president and
founder of Order Flows Trading. And what
it is, it's you know, it's an
educational company and it's also a
software company. And
today's presentation is going to be a
little bit different than a lot of the
webinars that you attend in the past.
You know, it's because I want to educate
you so that you could take charge of
your trading and you know, become a
trader. You know, one of the reasons why
many traders fail is because you know,
they don't know how to trade. They just
think that they can blindly follow other
people
with their trading advice and you know,
have a nice red light green light system
telling them where to buy or sell. And
today you're in for a treat because I'm
going to share with you,
um you know, five solid methods of using
order flow that you
can apply to your trading tomorrow. So,
the first one is recognizing market
transitions in supply and demand with
the order flow delta, how to identify
distribution and accumulation at tops
and bottoms for low risk trades,
what is stopping volume? I'll explain it
and explain how to use it it to your
advantage. And I'll show you how to
easily see price rejection to keep you
in winning trades longer. And lastly,
I'm going to show you how to use order
flow to determine where a bar will often
pull back to as soon as it opens.
And if you stick around till the end,
I'll give you a copy of my book, Trading
Order Flow. It's a 150 page book. You'll
receive um
the digital download. You won't receive
an actual copy in the mail, um but it
you'll receive a download that you can
print up or save to your uh
tablet or smartphone. So, why order
flow, right? As a trader, you have to
deal with what's happening right now,
right in front of you on the trading
screen and the best way to describe it
is like looking at the Doppler radar,
right? You know, I live in Chicago and
you know, I could look at the weather
on a weather map, but I'm really
concerned with what's happening right
now. Is the storm right above me?
Now, order flow specifically, the volume
footprint chart takes all the price and
volume data and logically organizes it
in a chart format so the trader can see
price and volume patterns other traders
don't see. You can see how buy and sell
orders are trading and impacting the
market right now. And why is this
important? It's because you know,
there's a lot of people talk about
different forms of order flow like
trading on a price ladder, the depth of
market.
And all you're looking at is people's
intentions to trade, you know, the
market is five bit at six, but there's a
thousand offered at eight. Oh my gosh,
there's such a big offer there. Well,
the market's only five bit at six. You
got to be concerned with what's right in
front of you. How is the market reacting
to five bit at six?
And I'm going to show you how to use the
order flow to determine if the market
will continue in its current direction.
And basically, with order flow, you're
going to have a better and more complete
information than the majority of traders
because they're only looking at
the open, high, low, and close of bars.
They're not looking at the volume that's
going on right now. They're not looking
at and not understanding how bars are
forming and why the market is moving.
And again, it's it's like looking at the
Farmer's Almanac trying to predict the
weather as opposed to looking at the
Doppler radar and seeing what is right
above you right now.
So, those of you that are new to
order flow and new to one of my
presentations, just a brief background
on myself. I don't want to spend a lot
of time, but I want you to understand
where I'm coming from. My name is
Michael Valtos and I started in the
early 90s on the CME floor as a runner
with Dean Witter Reynolds. You know,
back in those days when we had trading
floors, that's the lowest level you can
start at. But I realized if I want to
get into trading, I have to start
somewhere. And you know, I left a job
that was paying me, you know, when I was
21 years old, 22, you know, paying me
close to 35,000 back in the early 90s,
which back then, 20 21 years old, making
more than your age, you're thinking
you're living large. But I realized I
had to quit that job and start at the
bottom in the trading industry, and
that's what I did. And eventually I left
the trading floor and I went to the
upstairs trading desk
at Dean Witter when electronic trading
started taking off. You know, I was
there Globex trader, me and a and a
group of other other traders. We had
about a total 24-hour desk running, you
know, probably about six or seven people
each shift.
All told, I spent about 3 years at Dean
Witter.
And that was a great experience because
I got exposed to electronic trading at a
time when it was just starting, right?
That was the infancy. You know, CME had
Globex, CBOT had Project A.
NYMEX, COMEX had um the access system.
You know, each exchange had their own
trading system. It's not like now where
you just connect to um you know,
basically the CME Group owns all the
exchanges, but you know, now everything
comes in via one pipe. Before you had to
have different pipes for each exchange.
After that, I left uh Dean Witter. I
joined EDF Man in Chicago in the global
macro trading desk.
EDF Man is a big English trading firm.
It has been around since the 1700s. They
uh they got their start trading sugar.
They're big in commodities. After that,
I spent 3 years at Commerzbank in
Chicago. I was a licensed Eurex trader.
I traded Bunds, Bobl,
um Schatz, DAX, Euro Stoxx. This was in
um
the late 90s.
And this was a time when
you know, electronic trading was really
starting to take off. We still had the
floors, but Eurex was all electronic. It
was like the first exchange that was
purely electronic. And I spent 3 years
there. I learned how, you know, the
importance of trading European 10-year
notes against US 10-year notes,
um you know, trading DAX and Euro Stoxx
against E-minis and Nasdaq.
And after that, I joined Cargill, which
is the big American trading company. You
know, it's a privately held company. If
it was public, it would probably be
about the second or third largest
company in the United States. They trade
everything there. You know, they they
the whole supply chain. You know, they
account for about 30% of the
agricultural exports of the United
States, about also a similar amount of
meat exports. You know, but they also
trade um oil, and involved in shipping.
You know, probably about 25% of all the
ships out in the sea is leased Cargill
cuz they're they're they're big on
shipping the commodities around the
world. So, I learned, you know, the
relationships with commodities and how
it ties in to more of you know, the
whole global scheme of trading.
And then, after Cargill, I spent 8 years
at JP Morgan as vice president of
futures trading. You know, being from
Chicago, I've always I'm a futures guy,
okay?
And I spent 8 years at JP Morgan on the
trading desk. I wasn't sitting in some
office, you know, looking at
spreadsheets coming out, tapping the
trader on the shoulder, uh you know,
you're you're you're exceeding your your
parameters, stop trading like that. No,
you know, I was there banging away at
the keyboards um for 8 years. Sometimes
I loved it, sometimes I hated it, but
you know, it was it was great
experience.
After birth of my first daughter, I was
like, I can't take this anymore. I got
no life because I was coming into the
office at just before 6:00 a.m. and I
was leaving about 5:00 p.m.
So, I was spending basically as much
time, if not more, in the office than
with my family. So, I left. So, I I
don't want to do this anymore. I was you
know, 43 at the time
and I said that's it. I walked away from
a very successful institutional trading
career and I started trading for myself.
Over time
about a year or two later
I started developing the Order Flows
Trader software. Now, I was trading with
order flow before and I was using
another company's software, but it was
it was kind of basic, right? It was just
a volume footprint chart. And at this
time I was writing my book also, you
know, with how I trade with order flow,
what I look for in the order flow. And I
said, you know, why can't the software
do this analysis for me? So, I met with
a programmer who already understood
order flow and I said, you know, I want
to take all this knowledge and put it
into the chart so it can highlight to me
areas of support areas of resistance
areas of price rejection areas of
stopping volume, you know, areas where
market is being swept and etc. And
that's how the Order Flows Trader
software was born. Initially, I wanted
to keep it just for myself because you
know, I didn't think there's going to be
a big market for it. I didn't think you
know, other traders would be interested
in it, you know, cuz at that time, you
know, back in you know, the mid
teens, you know, 2013, 2014, you know,
order flow traders you know, there was a
very small group of them, right? People
didn't really put much into the order
flow. But over time, you know, it's
expanded as you know, information on
order flow trading came out and people
were interested in it and that's how
the Order Flows Trader software was born
as the Order Flow under orderflows.com.
Now, it runs on NinjaTrader 8. You know,
it's a retail platform, but let's be
honest, we're all retail traders unless
you're working for a bank. And if you're
a bank, you got big resources, right?
But for the majority of us
we need to trade on a retail platform,
which is
most of us trade with NinjaTrader. So,
the charts you see in this presentation
are generated from the Order Flows
Trader, which runs on Ninja Trader 8.
And what I'll be sharing with you today
is what I used
in my institutional trading career and
now use in my own trading. You know, the
barriers to entry in the financial
industry have changed over the last 15
years, right? When I started, there was
exchange floors. You could literally
walk down to the floor, befriend
somebody, and by the end of the day,
hopefully, have a lead on a job. Now,
trading firms are only hiring
mathematicians and scientists. You know,
you They're only taking people from top
schools with certain degrees. And the
opportunity isn't there for new traders
to learn from existing traders, cuz
you're not going to get in those jobs.
Whereas before you go to the trading
floor,
and you can meet with you can talk with
successful traders, people trading in
the pit. You know, and eventually it
will lead to other relationships where
you get to meet the people on the other
side of the phones, you know, some of
the the greatest traders in the world.
So,
before I begin, you know, I want to take
this time to invite all of you to follow
me on YouTube. Just go to Order Flow. Go
to YouTube, search Order Flows,
subscribe to the channel. You know, I've
got about 250 videos on there. It's very
informative. You know, people always ask
me, "What's a great place to start with
Order Flow?" Say, "Watch my videos." You
know, that that's it's free.
And that's a great place to start.
But before I jump into everything, you
know, a brief disclaimer. You know, I
want you to understand trading is risky,
especially in today's environment. All
right? You know, the volatility
the VIX is at such high levels that
you know, trading right now for a lot of
people, they are getting hammered. There
are people also making a lot of money, a
lot of quick money, which I think
sometimes is a bit of of a bad thing,
because, you know, sometimes people in
market environments where it's so
choppy, people think trading is easy,
because they just put a bid and offer
in, and within a second they're filled
on both, and they just made 100 bucks.
They think, "Oh, this is easy." But, the
reality is, you know, markets will calm
down. You know, this extreme
volatility, these wild price
fluctuations are not normal.
It will take a while for the markets to
return to their normalcy.
So,
over the last 5 years, since I've been
dealing with retail traders, you know,
in the past, you know, working in
institutional side, you know, I I was
surrounded by very good traders, you
know, traders that literally have books,
written books, you know, traders that
have been worked at all the major
trading firms and
you know, I've been exposed to a lot of
different trading methods.
But, when I now, over the last 5 years,
working with,
you know, retail traders,
I I understand what a lot of the
problems are that they're facing is
because they just deal with one piece of
information and they're trying to take
that one piece of information
and make all their trading decisions
based around it, right? They're trying
to find exactness in the market with
just one piece of information and that
one piece of information is price,
right?
But, they're missing a big, important
component. The big, important component
is volume, right? Because volume is the
piece of information that tells you the
commitment of other traders to the
market, right? It's going to help you
identify the behavior of the other um
traders you're competing against, right?
It's
I I don't want to say trading against,
even though you are trading against
them, but in reality, you're competing
against them.
Okay? And you have to, you know, if
you've ever run a race, you know,
sometimes, you know, you're getting
close to the finish, you know, you're
trying to elbow the guy next to you, try
to get that little bit of an edge, you
know, you're looking there, can I can I
lean my head forward? You want to get
that little bit of an edge to finish
first. And you know, people say, "But,
Mike, you know, volume, yeah, yeah, I
don't need a not that important, Price
is important. Well, if you've ever run a
business, right? Now, so many people run
online businesses,
you know, from home, right? They sell on
eBay, they sell on Amazon, they got a
Shopify store. Well,
they don't just keep track of the price
of the item they sell at, they keep
track of There's so many analytics,
right? They they see that well, if I
start this price, if I start selling
this book at this price,
I sell a lot more.
You know, like in the old days of eBay,
you you'd have an item, you could start
it at 99 cents, you'd get a lot of
interest in it, as price would go up.
But then if you take that same item and
you put it out there, say, well, I'm
going to sell it for $100,
even though it's worth $200, you're
going to get nothing, right? You get one
bid late in the auction, and you sell it
for $100 when you could have sold it for
$200 starting at um 99 cents. So, you
know, you're going to take into account
all these other factors, like what am I
selling at this price? What am I selling
at that price? What am I selling at this
price? And, you know, if you've ever run
a business, you know, you're going to
have a a break-even price
that, you know, if you're above or below
it, it doesn't matter. If you're below
it, you could sell a million copies of a
book, but if you're 1 cent below that
break-even price, it's pointless, right?
So, once you understand the importance
of volume, you can begin to analyze it
and find hidden trading opportunities
that traders are overlooking. Why they
overlooking at it? It's no secret,
they're not looking at volume, right?
Remember, markets trade in a two-way
auction. There's a bid at one price and
an offer at a higher price. And
in the two-way auction,
right? For a trade to occur, a trader
must buy the offer or sell the bid.
Otherwise, the market will just stand
still, no trading will occur, right? In
the past,
a lot of exchanges, especially the ones
in Asia, they used to have basically a
fixing, right? They say when I say in
the past, in the US, that's how it used
to do it, you know, a century ago, is
they they basically say, okay, everyone
will come in, up work their bids and
offers, and then boom, when everybody is
satisfied, that's the one price
everything will trade at." We don't do
that anymore. We trade in a two-way
auction, and we've been doing this for a
long time now in the US. And basically
what you have is you have a bid and an
offer. You can see this is a dome,
right? This is the Ninja Trader dome
on What's this? The E-minis. For a trade
to occur, someone has to buy at the
market or sell at the market.
And
you're going to Basically, in this case,
the market is 2456 bid, offered at 2456
and a quarter. Everybody that's working
to buy it at 56 and below is what's
considered a passive trader. Everyone
that's working to sell it at 56 and a
quarter and above is also a passive
trader. But, for a trade to occur,
somebody at 56 and below has to get
aggressive and buy it at 56 and a
quarter.
That's what you call an aggressive
trader. They're going to aggressive
trader is going to buy from a passive
trader. Just as if the market was to go
down, someone on the passive side, on
the offer, someone that's working at 56
and a quarter, 56, or even someone just
coming into the market, "Oh, I think the
market's going down. I just want to sell
it at the market." They sell the 56s.
They sell the 55 and 3/4. That trader is
being aggressive. They are hitting the
bid. They're selling at the market
price.
And once you understand
how trading works,
then you can start to understand order
flow, right? And there's three key data
points in order flow that you need to
know. Delta, imbalance, point of
control. Now, this chart here, this is
an order flow footprint chart.
Okay?
And it takes all that information that
you just saw on the dome when a trade
occurs and it puts it into a nice
easy-to-read format, and from that
format it generates other pieces of
information, okay? Which I will go
through. first is the delta. Okay? The
delta on most software, mine especially,
it runs it on the bottom. Okay? Delta,
max delta, min delta, cumulative delta.
Okay? It's the net difference in a bar
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers. If a bar has positive deltas,
you would say buyers are in control of
that bar. The bar has negative deltas,
sellers are in control of that bar. Now,
there's a max delta, which is the
strongest delta was in a bar at one
point. You have a min delta,
which is the most negative delta was in
a point. Now, max delta could be zero,
min delta could be zero.
Generally,
you know, on one-way
bars, you know, bars that just shoot
straight up or bars that shoot straight
down, you may get you know, a bar
shooting straight up, you'll have
all max delta,
zero min delta. Just as a bar that goes
straight down, basically, even though
there is counter trade in the bar, at no
point were buyers in control. You would
if the bar was straight down, everyone
is hitting the bid, there might be some
counter trade, and but at no point were
max was max delta positive, so at no
point in that bar were buyers in
control.
Now, the next point is imbalances. Okay?
Now, imbalances occur in the two-way
auction between the volume traded on the
bid versus volume traded on the offer.
And generally,
if it's greater than 4:1, you consider
it an imbalance. So, remember, right?
The market trades bid against the offer.
Okay? So,
you know, for example, here on this
chart,
um yeah, 174.53,
it traded zero. At 174.54, it traded 115
contracts right here, right? The two-way
auction.
Okay? So, zero against 115, obviously,
it's greater than 4:1. That's why the
number is blue. You have a buying
imbalance. Now, up here at the top of
the bar, you got 257 traded at 58 versus
three traded at 59.
The 257 against three obviously is
greater than four to one. This is a
selling imbalance. That's why the number
is red in the bar. Okay? And there's
ways you can interpret the imbalances in
a bar.
I've got a lot of great videos on my
YouTube channel about that. And lastly
is point of control. And it's simply the
price level in a bar where the most
volume traded. And it can often act as
support or resistance.
Or some people like to say supply and
demand over the next bar or bars.
And you can see here every bar has a
point of control, whether it's a red
candle or a green candle, it has a point
of control. Now, the beauty of point of
controls is there are some cases where
the point of control is very important.
It
It represents, you know, stopping
volume. It represents a big offer coming
into the market or a big buyer coming
into the market. And it can act as a
floor or a ceiling
in the short term at least. Sometimes it
acts as as support or resistance over
the longer term. Again, it depends on
the type of chart you're trading,
whether you're trading a one-minute
chart
or you're trading, you know, a 15-minute
chart. If you're trading a one-minute
chart,
I wouldn't look at, you know, a certain
point of control as being support for
the entire day. If I was looking at a
15-minute chart and I saw an
important point of control, one that
mattered, it might very well be the
support for the entire day. Now, it's
through the delta, the imbalances, and
point of control that a trader can see
inside the bar and understand the market
internals. You know, most
traders think they're looking at a
candlestick chart. They think that
they're reading the order flow because a
red candle represents a bar that opened
high and closed lower. A green candle
represents the opposite, a bar that
opened low and closed higher. Well, I'm
reading the order flow because obviously
buyers are in control of that bar.
Well,
in a basic sense, yeah, you got to also
remember,
depending on the type of chart you're
looking at, it's time constricted. So,
if you're looking at a minute base
chart, it can just close
even though if you were to give it an
extra 2 seconds, it might instead of
being a green candle, it could be a red
candle. You're not really understanding
what's going on in the market, what's
going on in the order flow.
So,
let's take what we've just learned about
order flow and start applying it to the
market. So, let me get into the five
practical uses of order flow
in trading that you could go take away
from and, you know, if you have a
footprint chart, you know, you can start
looking for
um
for these situations. So, the first one
is recognizing market transitions in
supply and demand with order flow. And
like I said earlier, right? Delta is the
net difference between the aggressive
buyers
and aggressive sellers in a bar. Every
bar has aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers present, but when one group is
clearly in charge, it's going to help
determine the direction of the market.
And that's important because,
you know, generally speaking, a market
will rise on positive delta because
buyers are buying the existing supply
and willing to pay higher prices for
more supply. Right? We've seen it with
this um
panic buying, you know, ahead of
government shutdowns everywhere. You
know, every There's a lot of demand for
everything. You know, people are are
buying all the existing supply even if
the stores raise the prices, you know, a
little bit, you know, they they still
buy more. Now, when a market sells off,
you see negative delta in bars because
sellers are aggressively distributing
their supply. They're hitting the bids,
and they're looking for buyers and
selling to them. You know, if
all of a sudden Charmin comes out with,
you know,
10 warehouses full of of toilet paper
and then starts putting them into the
market, people will still buy them, but
at some point people will realize, "Hey,
I got you know, I got 100 rolls of
toilet paper right now. I don't need any
more."
To move those toilet paper, Charmin's
going to have to keep lowering the
price.
You know, as as
people well, you know, I don't want to
buy it at, you know, $5 a roll, but I'll
buy it at $1 a roll. All right, so it's
going to take some time for Charmin to
get the price down, right? With their
supply.
So,
like I said, as markets go up,
delta is generally positive, right? You
can see here as the market is going up,
mostly you have been positive deltas.
You do get, you know, the occasional
down bar here.
You know, small bar with negative delta,
right? But the as the markets go up, you
see nice positive deltas.
So, markets start coming off a little
bit, you got negative deltas, all right?
This little patch in here, negative
deltas. Market starts going up, you got
positive deltas. Market starts coming
down, you got negative deltas.
All right, so that's how delta is going
to help you a bit, but
where a lot of traders get lost in order
flows putting the pieces together,
right? Order flow in isolation does give
you clues as to what's going to happen
next. But, when you put the pieces of
order flow together, you start to see
things happening in the market as it
happens right now, rather than later,
right? And when you start putting them
together in context, you start seeing
patterns occur. Now,
what I see here, okay, I I this is a
market that's transitioned from
a demand-driven to supply-driven market.
What do I mean by that is how do I how
can I tell? Well, I see all of a sudden
sellers taking control of the market.
You know, we're at our high, market's
going up, we got nice strong positive
delta, but we hit our high, sellers are
coming in, right? We got negative delta,
minus 40. Next bar, minus 86. Next bar,
minus 382. All right, so
you got to be asking yourself, you know,
anytime you hit a high or a low, is this
market going higher or lower?
Okay, and we hit our high and sellers
are attracted to these high prices. They
start coming in. Hey, this is this is a
great sell up here at 44. I want to get
some, right? They start selling it.
Other traders realize that, yeah, hey
man, this is a good sell. They start
selling, selling, selling, right?
Trading sometimes is a herd mentality,
right? Once
you know, back when there was a pit, you
know, sometimes you would see,
you know, people guys on the floor would
know
which
trader behind the phone was calling in,
right? So, they would they would know
that if if it was a Commerce Bank, you
know, at 3:00, if it was Commerce Bank
coming in to start trading the S&Ps,
they would know that um it was pro funds
behind it, you know, the big hedge fund,
you know, positioning themselves
for the market. So, other traders would
see that and they would come in and
start doing the same thing, right? With
traders, there is a herd mentality. So,
you know, once you start seeing the
selling coming in here, everyone else
starts seeing it, starts coming off, and
you see by the time you get to the
second blue bar here,
you know, this is the area you'd be
getting short. You know, that that's a
nice that's a quick 20-point drop right
there in the S&Ps on a 1-minute chart.
Okay, now what do you have here, right?
Again, S&Ps, this time it's a 5-minute
chart. People say, why you show a
1-minute chart? Why you show a 5-minute
chart?
You know, can't is there is am I
supposed to keep flipping back and
forth? No, you know, I want you to see
that it works whether using a 1-minute
chart, whether using a 5-minute chart,
whether using a 5,000 volume chart, or
you know, a range-based chart,
concepts of order flow apply to those
types of charts as well. But, in this
today, I'm just going to show mostly um
just 1-minute charts and I think
5-minute charts all in the E-minis,
maybe a crude chart thrown in here or
there.
So, we're coming into the low.
We hit our low. All of a sudden, you see
positive delta getting stronger, right?
We hit the low, we got a strong negative
delta minus 1349. That's like the last
push of sellers coming in. All of a
sudden, people realize, "Hey, this is
cheap." They start buying it. Getting
stronger. Next bar, buying more. Next
bar, buying more. Then the next bar, you
know, you're talking a move from 26 all
the way up into the 50s.
Because what's happened is the market
has transitioned from, you know, supply
coming into the market and helping move
the market lower to all of a sudden
demand coming into the market at these
lower prices.
This is what I actually I have an
indicator on my website. It's called the
delta surge. But again, you know, if you
just look at the delta, you can see
this. Right? You can see how, you know,
first, you know, you had you you're sort
of going sideways. Then the negative
delta starts expanding, right? Minus 59,
minus 604, minus 662. Market drops a
little bit, you know, about
10-15 points.
Then sort of comes back up again. Starts
going sideways around that same level.
And then more selling comes in. Second
wave of selling.
All right? This time, you know, you you
hit the high. As you hit your high, you
got your strongest negative delta bar,
right? It was creeping up a little bit.
Minus positive 274, minus 130, minus
520. And then boom, the sellers just
slammed
everyone that was buying it. You got
imbalances in the bar.
And then boom, it goes from 70 to 50
over the next three or four bars.
But again,
you don't need an indicator. You could
just look at the delta and see that
information. Actually,
I used to trade a commodity in Malaysia.
And it's called palm oil. You know,
unless you're
you know, sort of a an addict to the
markets, you're not going to know what
it is. But in Malaysia, you know, in the
US, you have soybean oil, you have
cooking oil, canola oil in Canada is a
big contract, but Malaysia, it's palm
oil. That's their biggest contract over
there. Even trades more volume than
their stock index. And
you know, but it's a very small market
and often times
you you have people accumulating
positions
without trying to move the market.
That's where
I first noticed this this pattern in the
order flow, right? We would be moving
basically, you know, back and forth,
back and forth.
And then I would I would just notice
sort of this pick up
when traders are starting to get
aggressive and you'd see it it often
times like this where it got slammed
right here. You'd see it boom. Finally,
you know, people that are distributing
their position, people are sitting all
these bids causing that negative delta
and finally overrun the people bidding
the market, you know, the people trying
to support the market, the passive
buyers sitting there working bids
thinking this market's going higher, but
I I can tell that the sellers are
getting more and more aggressive, right?
That they're not yet moving the market,
but I've found that usually after the
the third strong delta
in a direction either positive or
negative, that's when the move happens.
Again, this is E-minis. This is back to
a 1-minute chart. You're coming into a
swing low.
And you can see how the market just
boom, it just it's beautiful, right? It
just comes down in here.
You know, it's weak. It's weak. All of a
sudden, boom, you're at your low, but
instead of still showing weakness, it's
showing strength. You know, aggressive
buying coming in over the next three
bars and then boom, the market pops up.
You know, it's
it's not something that you're going to
see 100 times a day.
You know, depending on the market, you
may see it
you know,
three or four times a day,
but you know,
when it's there, take it in context with
what's happening in the market, right?
If you're looking to buy, you want to be
buying after the market sold off, right?
After market hits a low, you want to be
looking for aggressive buyers coming in.
You know, sometimes people will say,
"Well, you know, we just rallied all the
way up here 20 points and then, you
know, there was
three bars with strong positive delta
getting bigger,
but the trade didn't work. So, you know,
order flow is hogwash." But, they're not
using it in context of the market,
right? They said, "If the market just
rallied 20 points, rather than a point
to buy again, you know, potentially you
should be looking for a place to get
short if there's something in the order
flow."
So, again, you know, take everything in
context of the market. And, you know,
delta is, again, the net difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers in a bar. Once you all start
analyzing delta in relation to
surrounding delta, you see clear market
patterns. You know, it's like taking a
walk on the beach and you find a perfect
shell,
right? Among all the rocks, you know,
the
perfect pattern in mother nature, you
know, the nautilus shell. You know, it
occurs, right? It may not occur as often
as we like, but it occurs often enough
that you can take advantage of it. So,
the next
setup, next
I hate to call them setups, but the next
condition I want to explain is
distribution and accumulation at tops
and bottoms for low risk trades, you
know.
Low risk trades are something we all
strive for. We all want to have low risk
trades, right? Because you know, no one
wants to risk excess amount of money.
You know, at the end of the day,
we're all cheapskates, you know. I hate
to say it, but, you know, you want to
overpay for something, right? And, you
know, if you if you overpay for
something, you want to know that your
downside risk is limited.
Okay? You know, you spend a lot of money
buying a Ferrari, you know, your
downside risk is limited because there's
a big resale market, you know, if you
overspend on,
you you
a purse or something like that, a
jacket, you know, you probably overspent
and you know, it's not something that
you could easily resell and recoup your
money back, you know, so spending $5,000
on a Burberry raincoat, as my wife
really wants one,
you know, it's
it's it's it's not always a prudent
decision, you know, you can get her
practically good perfectly good raincoat
for $100, right? So, it's you know,
unless you're Montgomery Burns or
something, you know, it's you got to
think of the risk rewards, you know, why
why would you overpay for something?
You're taking a big risk on it. And
areas of accumulation or distribution
are generally low-risk entry areas
cuz once you realize and once you
recognize what's going on in the market
in the order flow, you can set tighter
stops. You have areas you can hide
behind. You know, what makes
accumulation and distribution trade
setups so attractive is they often occur
around daily highs
and lows as well as swing highs and
lows. So, you're you are trading around
market structure, you know, everyone
says, well, you know, I looked at market
structure, etc. And then I took my
trade. Well, most people don't
understand market structure, you know,
cuz I see them go out and they they do
the opposite of what really what they
should be doing. So,
let's take a look at this chart.
So, as the market trades sideways to a
little bit higher, what do you see?
Okay?
You see mostly negative delta.
Okay? Market is just
going nowhere. You got negative deltas,
okay? So, what's going on?
Well, aggressive sellers are hitting the
bids. There's
a lot of people working bids, but the
aggressive sellers keep hitting those
bids. So, two things are going to
happen. One,
either the aggressive sellers
are going to run out of supply. If
that's the case, expect the market to
keep going higher.
Or two,
the demand, you know, the people that
are buying, you know, working bids, you
know, if the market is, you know,
trading 46, people say, "Well, you know,
I'd be happy to buy it at 44." They work
bids at 44, 42.
You know, it trades down there, market
goes back up. These people that are
buying it at 44 and 42 are thinking,
"Yeah, I'm I'm a I'm a market wizard."
Um, you know, they so they keep working
bids, working bids, working bids.
But, those bids keep getting hit. They
think it's free money coming to them,
you know, because the market keeps
popping up. But, what's happening is
these sellers, these aggressive sellers,
keep hitting those bids, and then they
back off. They let the market go back
up. Gives people a false sense of
security. Market goes back up, they hit
those bids again. But,
sooner or later, one side is going to
win. All right, so you got to be
attentive to what's happening in the
order flow. You watch the deltas is is
is the key.
Because once the market starts selling
off, you know, price action traders
would get short, you know, underneath
the swing low, but order flow traders
are going to be getting short up here in
this congestion area because they're
looking for that break
before it breaks through a trend line.
All right, or before it breaks through a
swing low. All right, they're able to
recognize up here when we're trading in
the 40s, rather than down here when
we're trading in the 30s. So, you're
seeing, you know, the market is
basically going sideways, mostly
negative deltas, and then boom, you get
a big bar, big strong negative delta.
You know, previous bar, people say,
"Well, you had a big strong positive
delta." Okay, big strong positive delta,
but the next bar couldn't build on it.
All right, instead it became all
negative. It's all strong negative
delta. It's what your strongest negative
delta in the whole sequence.
And then you go inside with a small
delta of 90, then another strong bar
of minus 500 delta. All right, and
finally,
where's the bidders? They're gone. Boom,
the selling comes in. Minus 1,000 delta,
minus 1,500 delta, minus 800 delta,
minus 700 delta. As you drop from, you
know, 38
all the way down to 18
over a period of
4 minutes.
Right? That's how
putting together the delta over a period
and putting it in context of the market
is going to help you find low risk
trades. You know, if you're getting
short here, where's your stop? It's just
right up here, you know?
You have your swing high up here at what
was that like 49, but you have this
lower higher high here at 48 with the
big positive delta which I was like,
"Oh, this is it. We're going back up."
But the next bar couldn't even reach
that level.
Right? So, you're staying below 46. So,
if you're getting short, you know, at 44
you know, you you have a stop up here at
48 you know, to catch a big 20-point
move down.
So
I'm going to show you a sequence of
charts. This is part one, right? As the
market reaches new highs
it keeps registering positive deltas in
just about each bar, right? But once it
reaches the high, negative delta bars
appear. So, you know, we're marching up,
right? You got nice positive deltas each
bar.
Okay? Hit our high. What do we see now?
Negative deltas. Do you think this
market's going to go higher or lower at
this point? Well
we got one bar of positive delta 700.
Okay? But then sellers came back in
minus 400, minus 200, minus 385.
It didn't build on that positive delta.
Market's not going to go higher on
more negative delta even though, you
know, it did get a pop here in this bar.
Didn't trade a little bit higher, but
then the selling came in. Market starts
coming off, right? Where is your
positive delta that you saw on the run
up? Instead, you're seeing the opposite.
You're seeing negative delta, right?
This is the second half of this same
chart. What do you see as you see here
your high?
Again, it's just all negative deltas as
the market sells off. When you do get
positive deltas, they're relatively
small 249, you know, other than the 701,
but 249, 96, 50, 100, and 1 3 341, but
it's just being overrun by sellers.
Minus 400, minus 200, minus 385, minus
83, minus 390, minus 87, minus 221,
minus 443, minus 581, as the market
keeps tumbling.
So, once those aggressive buyers are
gone,
now this aggressive sellers are in
control, right? And you can see as as
the market sold off. Here's another
example. This one's a little bit more
choppy.
You know, you make your highs, you're
going up on you know, decent positive
deltas, you know, 800, 900, 1200, 1900,
but you're struggling here to go higher.
Why? It's because aggressive sellers are
coming in. Minus 500, minus 1,000, minus
you know, 286, 299. I mean, you know,
you get a bar here with some decent
positive delta, 400, but you can't even
reach the high.
And then it comes right back with the
big strong negative delta. Again, you
you put in a little half-hearted rally
back up here to the high,
but where's your strong delta that you
saw earlier? Earlier you saw 800, 900,
1200, 1900. Here you see 200, 300, 10.
10 is nothing. 10 is practically
neutral.
Might as well be minus 10. Then you got
268.
Then you're just hanging around the
high, minus 15, minus 17. Boom, minus
576.
Right? So, this takes us to where's
minus
minus 576. Again, you make that run back
up to the high again. This is just the
same chart, just a little bit later. You
make a third attempt at the high. You
can't even hit the high.
But as you know, you're you're two ticks
off the high, and again, it's just all
negative delta, minus 55, minus 122,
minus 647, minus 293 minus 376.
Yeah, at this point
what do you think is going to happen?
Where's your aggressive buyers to take
the market higher? They're not there.
So again, if you're getting short
somewhere in here, you know, around the
84 area,
you know, you could have a stop up here,
you know, just above high 88 or
something if you want, but it was really
you know, you got you in these markets
you got to have something like
end-of-the-world stop someplace. You
know, trading without stops in these
markets is is quite deadly, but you
know, I used to have what I call a
worst-case scenario stop, which would
be, you know, right above the high.
You know, maybe a point or two above the
high.
Just, you know, in the worst-case
scenario.
You know, so maybe I got a five-point
stop here, but it goes from, you know,
the 84 area down into the 60s.
So maybe I'm risking five points,
worst-case scenario, but honestly, if we
start coming back up here and I see
positive deltas, yeah, I'd get out at
half the loss rather than take a full
loss, but instead,
you're risking, you know, three to five
points to get 15 to 20 points.
So
here's a another example. This is the
market
at the low of the day, right? As a
trader, you should be asking yourself,
you know, anytime the market's at a
higher or the low,
what's the market going to do next? You
know, if we're at the low of the day,
are we going to go lower or are we going
to go higher? Are we going to get a
rally? So we're at our lows, we're just
hanging around the lows.
Okay? Do I see
more aggressive buying or more
aggressive selling? Well, I see mostly
positive deltas coming in here, right?
I'm picking up clues in the order flow
that buyers are aggressive at these
levels.
They are trying to buy as much as they
can without moving the price. You know,
that's what institutional traders do,
right? That's what these algos, fancy
algos do, the sophisticated ones for the
banks, you know, they want to
trade as much of a position as possible
without impacting the price. And if
we're at the low of the day and there's
an algo kicking off saying to buy it by
this boatload, they don't want to move
the price higher, right? They want to
get as much as they can in at these low
prices. Right? So, they buy some.
Right? But, it's showing up here in the
delta, right? It's mostly positive
deltas. Aggressive sellers aren't in
control of this low. Aggressive buyers
are. And finally,
the rest of the world picks up on it and
the market pops from 50 all the way up,
you know, over the next couple bars, you
know, close to 70.
But again, if you're buying down here,
you're buying it somewhere around 45,
you know, 46. Where's your stop? The low
of the day is 2 and 1/2. You know, say
you have a stop here at 40 and you're
buying it at 45. It's a five-tick stop.
For what? A move from 45 all the way up
to, you know, 60s, 65.
So,
you know, the most powerful computer, I
tell people, is the one between your
ears. It's your brain, right?
Recognizing accumulation and
distribution can be obvious at times
just by asking, "What is the market
doing right now?" For example, you know,
you're at a low. Is there still
aggressive selling or is there
aggressive buying present? Like just
like in the previous example. You know,
I like to play this game with my kids.
What do we know?
All right? Especially if they lose
something, you know, what do we know?
Where were you last playing with it? You
know, sort of go back and look at the
facts, you know, if we're at the low of
the day, but I don't see aggressive
selling or if I see aggressive selling
and it's not as strong as it was earlier
coming into that low, but I start to see
signs of aggressive buying, that's
telling me the market is getting primed
for a rally.
All right. So,
the third, um,
sort of trade setup I want to talk about
is stopping volume and how to use it to
your advantage, right? Stopping volume
is like a car hitting a brick wall.
Okay? And
the the thing that really drives me nuts
a lot about traders
is when they start looking at support or
resistance,
they think of it as a particular level,
one level. If price gets through it,
that's it. Support is broken or
resistance is broken. You know, they
they they look at it as one specific
price level. And again, that's what I
was talking about earlier where you
know, traders that rely solely on price
sort of get blinded by everything else.
Like, oh, if we violate this price by
one tick, then it's invalidated. No, it
it's not. Um you know,
that just basically shows a not a
firm understanding of how the markets
trade. You know, even if you know,
there's an iceberg order, there's going
to be times where
you know, the the order has to reload
and you can tick through it. And also,
even that's not exact. But
there are several ways to see stopping
volume in the market. And
you know, for those of you that are
familiar with stopping volume is, it's
basically a big offer coming into the
market to stop the move up or a big bid
coming into the market to stop the move
down. And the easiest way to look for
them is in the point of controls. And
every bar has a point of control. But
when there is a bar with a point of
control that matters or one that will
act as support or resistance, that's
what I refer to as a prominent point of
control. Now, the Order Flows Trader
software is going to highlight to you
when one appears. Right, before I was
showing you in Delta, right? You don't
need your Order Flows Trader software,
but if you have the Order Flows Trader
software, I want to show you some of the
features here that you can use to
identify
market generated information such as a
prominent point of control, which is
stopping volume. Right? Again, you know,
you got to let the computer sometimes do
the work for you. Now,
in the software, there's a setting
called POC Trader,
and it allows you to set up to three
levels of prominent points of control.
And I used to have this as a separate
indicator,
separate tool rather, but
I incorporated into the main order flow
traders because it became such a regular
part of my analysis. Like in the past, I
would sort of just eyeball it and say,
"Yeah, I think that one's a stopping
volume." But, you know, with the
computer, it can do the work for me and
it will highlight the areas where
there's stopping volume in the market.
And as you can see,
it will color it
magenta for resistance or cyan, which is
like a a light blue, for support.
There's actually three here, right?
There's one over here which I didn't
highlight, but you can see how the next
bar traded right up to that level, came
off. It did come back up, get through
that area, but this area, even if you
were to draw that line, is acting as a
resistance area. But over here, you have
a a lower resistance area, and you can
see how the market keeps coming back up
there, keeps coming back up there, keeps
coming back up there before it finally
pukes out and falls over.
All right, people, you know, there's
somebody in here with offers
holding down the market, all right?
They're offering resistance.
That's what stopping volume is.
Stopping volume is going to stop a move,
right? Here,
sharp move up, boom, sharp move down,
but there's supportive volume in the
market coming in here,
right? You can see this point of control
aligns with these point of controls
earlier
to the left, right? You got three point
of controls at the same level. The
market does trade two ticks through.
You know, again, it's not the end of the
world. Oh my gosh, we traded two ticks
through, you know, this this prominent
point of control stuff is rubbish. No,
you know,
especially in these volatile markets,
sometimes you you you got to realize,
right? You just came from 35 down to 25,
bounced up a little bit. There's still a
little bit of selling pressure left to
get through, and then boom, once that
selling pressure is exhausted,
support comes back in the market. Market
rallies back up.
Okay.
Again, the stopping volume is going to
cap moves up. But more importantly, it's
going to help you find reversals early.
Again, here's a nice
capping volume, right? Stopping volume
up here.
The high of this red bar. And again,
you're alerted to this as soon as it's
forming, right? This is a 1-minute
chart. If you're trading a 1-minute
chart, you know that at 55 seconds,
chances are that bar is going to finish
the way it looks after 55 seconds on a
minute chart. And if you're getting
short, you know, you can be getting
short up here around the 50 area, 49-50
area.
People that are drawing trend lines are
drawing them from the swing low here,
drawing up like that. You know, they're
getting short in here when we break the
trend line at, you know, whatever, 45 or
44. You're getting in a full five points
earlier than everybody else using
traditional
um technical analysis.
Right? Now, for volatile
times like now, if you want if you want
to expand the prominent point of
control, you could actually, you know,
expand it to a level of five. I I don't
want to get into all these settings
right now, but I just want to show you
um if you're looking at a longer-term
chart, right? People say, "Well, I look
at a 15-minute chart. Can order flow
help me?" You know, this is a 5-minute
chart.
Sort of what I call expanding the net.
Here you got a nice prominent point of
control sticking out up here, right?
It's like a sore thumb showing up in
here around the 2600 area.
You know, over the next couple of bars,
you got plenty of time to be getting
short around the 92 to 95 area before it
sells off below 70.
Again, that's a 5-minute chart. You
know, people always ask, "Well, I trade
a 5-minute chart. I trade a 15-minute
chart. Can I use order flow?"
Yeah, you you can, you know, but you
know, you might have to adjust some of
the settings a little bit. Like if
you're using a prominent prominent point
of control, you want to expand it a bit.
Here's another beautiful example on a
5-minute chart.
Again, you know, you don't have to wait
till the 5 minutes and you know, people
say, "Well, normally me, I like to wait
for the bar to end." But honestly, if
I'm trading a a time-based chart, I know
that when the timer gets down to you
know, a few seconds, it's pretty safe to
uh take the trade.
And look at that, you know, it's a move
from the 70s again down into the 50s.
So,
points of control
are very revealing to a trader in
relation to value and volume. You know,
when POCs occur around swing highs or
lows, it can very often
signal a reversal in the market because
there's important volume there to stop
and reverse a move. You know, the order
flow straight or analyzes the order flow
to highlight these prominent points of
control for you. Now, the fourth one is
let me show you
how to easily see price rejection to
keep you in winning trades longer. And
as I was preparing this, I I realized
I also want to show you another way to
use price rejection. But let's talk
about price rejection first. What do you
think happens when traders reject a
price level? Put it in context, okay?
Always put trading in context. The bar
opens and starts trading. What's going
on?
The market is looking for price
acceptance, right? At a price level
where there's acceptance, traders are
happy to transact. At a level of price
rejection, few traders transact. So,
think about that. Where you have price
acceptance, traders are happy to
transact. That's going to be your point
of control. Your POC, your area with the
most volume because generally that's
going to be your value area for that
bar. But
at levels that they reject, there's
going to be very little trade. People
don't want to be buying the high. People
don't want to be selling the low.
So, how does a trader see it in the
order flow? Well, you look at the edges
of the bar for abnormally small volume.
Now, again, what is abnormally small
volume?
It depends on the market and time frame
you're looking at. You know, it's safe
to say volumes of 10 or less is small or
even in less liquid markets like say the
NASDAQ, you know, volumes of five or
less is going to be small.
Again, it's going to depend on your
market and one of the obvious benefits
is
being able to keep track of the volume
being traded on the bid and the volume
traded on the offer, right? That's the
benefit of order flows, keeping track of
that information. Again, you know, if
you're looking at time and sales
or a DOM, oh god, your head's going to
spin if you're if you're looking at
this. It's just going berserko, right?
You you're not going to keep track of a
time and sales, you know, and keeping
track in your head on a DOM is is just
as hard. You know, what most traders
think, you know, when when they start
trading with the DOM is is they think
they're Rain Man. They think they're
going to all of a sudden figure it out.
Well, honestly, I've been looking at
DOMs since
DOM trading started back in when the
electronic trading started and the
exchanges had the depth of market and
for a lot of traders, they don't really
understand what they're looking at. But
really, what the market is telling them
is, you know,
do you understand the words coming out
of my mouth? Do you understand
what you're seeing in the order flow?
And
let's be a realistic, right?
You got to
look think of the current market
situations, okay?
All right? And trying to figure out
what's happening
in the DOM
is is going to give you a headache,
right? The market's going to be moving
super fast that you know, trying to
figure it out is is just going to be,
you know, too much for
for anybody, you know, honestly. It's
you know, keeping track of what you're
looking at in the DOM is is
is going to be blinding. It's just going
to be happening so fast that you can't,
okay? I thought that was video I was
supposed to be working there but it's
it's not. Oh, there it is. But this is
the dome. This is Look at the S This is
Nasdaq. This is a few weeks ago when
we're trading in the 9,000s. Try keeping
track of that information that's going
through on you you know on your dome.
It's
practically impossible for most people,
right? And you say, "Well, I'm going to
look at a dome and become a successful
dome trader." Well, in the 3 seconds it
sold off from you know, 49 down to 45
and
you're not going to remember what
happened at 47. You're not going to
remember what happened at 48.
So, you know, for for a lot of people
trying to figure out what's happening in
the dome is is a waste of time, right?
Being able to keep track of reference
points, price levels where interesting
trading occurred is going to give you an
edge over other traders, right?
Cuz
why again you know, the benefit of order
flow, right? It's going to give you
references. It's going to put it on the
chart. It's going to put you
basically everything that's traded on
the dome on the time and sales.
It's going to paint it for you on the
chart. It's going to fill in that
information, volume traded at price. So,
you can maintain perspective of what's
happening when the market heats up,
right? When the market is moving fast,
you know, you don't have to sit there
and try to rely on your memory, right?
You want to be able to remember you want
to be able to identify the behavior of
other traders that you're trading
against. And if prices are being
rejected, you want to know which price.
Now,
when I released the initial version of
Order Flow Trader many years ago,
this was
a main component of it, right? It's what
I call small digit prints. It highlights
price rejection. Now,
it can be used in two ways to keep you
in winning trades longer and show you
potential trades, okay? Potential
reversals. First, I'm going to show you
how price rejection single digit prints
will let you stay in the winning trades
longer. If you are long, you want the
market to go up, right? Obviously, a
sign of a market going up is higher
highs, but also a sign of a market going
up is lower prices getting rejected.
So, a clear sign that lower prices are
being rejected in
is in subsequent bars in a move. You see
very little volume being traded on the
move up. And what this order flow trader
software will do, which I showed you
that little setting, you can set the
volume to highlight where
you know, it'll put a little box around
a green up candle if it's
price at the bottom of the bar is being
rejected. Well, everyone's going to say,
"Well, Mike, you know, every bar has got
a low, so the low is being rejected."
Yeah, but
there's certain times where the volume
that's being traded there is
very little in relation to normal order
flow, okay? Bars trade normal order flow
fairly regularly. It's when you don't
have the normal order flow that you want
to be alerted. Honestly, before I even
put this in the software, I used to just
trade this. I would just sit back and
look for these bars that had very small
volume at the bottom, and I would just
trade the next bar.
You know, here, right? If I trade this
first one,
buy it at the open, get out at the
close.
Next bar.
You know, I could do the next bar also,
but if I come here, I buy it at the
open, it starts going up, then it comes
down. Okay, I take a small loss. Next
one, I buy at the open, I get long, go
up.
Here's a This is a sell up here, but I'm
just showing you as the market moves up.
You know,
here you have price rejection on the top
of this red bar. You know, I get short,
boom, get out on the close. There's so
many different ways you could use it,
but
you know, in the crudest sense, that's
how I used it in the past.
Again, here's more signs of price
rejection as the market is moving
higher.
Right? So, if you're in
a position, say you're long or short,
what you want to be looking for is
you know, signs of
footprints, so to speak.
So, it's called the footprint chart, you
know, trail being left behind that those
prices are being rejected, you know, a
clear sign that higher prices are being
rejected in subsequent bars. In a move
down as you see very little trading at
the tops of red candles. For example,
right? If I'm short somewhere in here,
right? And this market starts selling
off and I'm seeing red candle or sorry,
I'm seeing price rejection, price
rejection, price rejection. It's going
to tell me, you know, hey, I could stay
in that trade a little longer even if I
see, you know, a potential prominent
point of control like this one down
here.
You know, but then I see, well, market,
yeah, you know, maybe I want to get out,
but what? I'm still seeing price
rejection, right? It's going to keep me
in that trade a little bit longer.
So, as the market move lower, there's
price rejection, right? We got a nice
stack selling imbalance in here. We got
three imbalances.
Right? We trade up through it, price
rejection. Okay, I'm getting short.
Next another bar, price rejection. Okay.
I come in here. Well, I got a bullish
prominent point of control. Market
rallies up, rallies back up into my
resistance. This is what I talk about
being able to put the pieces together.
But then it closes down. Okay, so this
I'm a little wary of this bullish
prominent point of control. I'm looking
at a lot of bearish things in here,
right? Next bar, two bars later,
a price sign of price rejection. So,
instead of saying, well, I'll just cover
it down here. Well, no, wait. I got some
sign of price rejection here, which
follows the price rejection from the
previous bars. And then boom, the market
drops from 70
down to 50s.
Okay, so I'm able to stay in that trade
longer, then hits a price rejection, a
bullish price rejection at the low of
the day. What happens? Market trades
right back up to that area where we were
earlier.
So,
the other way
that sort of leads into this next part
is using single digit prints
to find reversals in the market, right?
And if you're looking at a candlestick
chart, you're not going to see this
information. You're not going to see the
volume traded at the bottoms here,
right?
But if you're looking at a footprint
chart, you would see oh, I only traded
one. What's happening? You come down
here, you trade 12 on the bottom. Come
down here, boom, it hits it a little bit
more, 24.
33 again. Market rallies back up,
selling comes back in. Doesn't hit the
bottom next bar, one lot trades. Where
are those sellers? Earlier you had 33,
earlier you had 24. You only got one
this time. Market snaps back. Imagine
you're buying this next bar, you know,
at 40. What is that? 47. Just the one
bar,
right? 47 all the way up into the 60s
before it closes.
But again, if you're looking at
a bar chart, you're not going to notice
that. You're going to say, "Well, you
know, the bar was green or something.
You know, we tested it once, two, three,
four times, then it didn't work."
Uh you know, I wouldn't have bought that
bar. Most people wouldn't have bought
this bar. But if you're watching the
order flow, you would have. Most people
say, "Yeah, I would have caught that."
But reality is no, they wouldn't have,
right? They wouldn't have.
Okay, here's a nice swing low coming
down into the swing low. A nice V shape,
right? Boom, sharp move down, sharp move
back up. What's the sign?
Four. Now again, there's the signs in
the delta as well,
that this market is also getting ready.
You also got imbalances as well, but the
first clue, most obvious clue is that
small digit print right there at the
bottom. Now,
you can adjust
the size right here. It's small print
size limit five.
I prefer nine. That's what I've always
looked for because it would give me a
single digit. But, you know, for very
liquid markets I said, you know, up till
about 3 weeks ago,
you know, on S&P's on a minute base
chart you could use 25, you know, for 10
years.
You know, if you're using like a
5-minute chart, you could use 25. For
thinner markets, you know, like NASDAQ,
I use five. Okay? But again, it depends
on the market, the duration that you're
using. If you're using a a 30-second
chart or 1-minute chart,
you
you understand what is a small print for
you, right? Most bars are going to have
a volume at the lows or volume at the
high that is normal.
Here I have it set to 10.
Or nine rather. So, we got the seven
here at the swing low. Here's a four.
Most bars, you know, you're looking at a
volume say it's 29 is average, 14 is
average, 23, 46. You know, nothing
special. 26, 41. It's when you get those
small digits, two.
You know, this one's a nine. Here's a
four.
You know, here's a seven.
You know, just as on the red candles,
six,
five,
four, six.
You know, here's a another example at
the high, right? Then you start putting
it together with other things, right?
You got a bearish
prominent point of control. You got your
small print up here.
And it's a nice move down.
I mean, it it's
You know, often times, you know, traders
like to have big fancy mathematical
formulas and and programs. All you got
to do is look at a chart, right? Small
print small digit prints on bar extremes
are sign of price rejection. Or you
could think of it as price exhaustion.
Traders are tired of that price and
don't want to trade it anymore. So, the
last one I'll talk about
is
using order flow to determine where a
bar will often pull back to as soon as
it opens, right? It's not magic.
You know, traders
are always sort of looking for this holy
grail, this magic
indicator, magic setup that is going to
give them the answer to the market, but
there is none, right? You're always
as a trader, I know for me, when I first
started out, one of the things that I
always wanted to understand is why
does a market, why does a bar pull back
to a certain level and continue on in
its original direction?
And again, if you're looking at a
candlestick chart or a bar chart, most
traders don't use bar charts anymore,
they use candlestick charts,
is cuz you know, traders are more visual
now.
And you know, candlestick takes into
account the open
and the relation to the close.
Is an individual bar has a lot of
fluctuations, right?
You know, this
green candle
could be a a 1-minute chart, it could be
a 5-minute chart, it could be a daily
chart.
But in this candle, there's a tug of war
going on. It could go up, come off, go
back up, sell off, rally up, come off
again before rallying, right? You see
this
play out
during the day. This could be, like I
said, you know, this chart here could be
a daily chart, it could be a a weekly
chart, it could be
a a second chart even. You know, for
example, okay?
Chart on the left
is a 1-second chart and that all this
price activity up, down, up, down
is this one bar here, right?
An individual bar is essentially a
trading session, but in a micro sense,
okay? So, if you're looking at
a daily bar, right back in the days,
back in the '80s and '90s, you know,
people were, unless you're trading on
the floor, most people really weren't
into intraday price fluctuations. Most
every trading system that was out there
was designed based on
um daily bars.
And
you know, people would always be racking
their brain, "Well, why did the market
pull back, especially to this level, you
know, to a particular level from the
previous day before rallying?" You know,
around that time market profile came out
and people started to understand that it
dealt with the value.
Right? They would they would look at the
market profile for the day. They would
have a a value area and oftentimes the
next day the market would pull back to
that value area,
test it,
and either break through it or continue
on in its original direction.
But with order flow,
you know, you can sort of take it on
a more micro sense, right?
So, the question is, how can you use the
information in order flow to to find
those areas where the current bar that
you're in can trade back to and react
from?
Okay, so in other words,
where can the current bar trade to and
put in a lower or a high and then
reverse?
Right? You got to
think about it for a second, right?
Think about on a smaller scale. And most
people are familiar with volume profile,
right? They're familiar with value area
highs, value area lows. Now, the point
of control
is a form of value in a bar. It's the
price level where the most volume
appears. And if you're familiar with
volume profile, you understand that your
point of control is the level with the
most volume for that day.
Okay?
Take it
on a smaller level. The point of control
is the level
where in the bar where the most volume
occurred.
Now, every bar has a point of control,
okay? And as you can see here, right? On
this move down,
right? Where does the bar trade back to?
It trades back up around the previous
bar's point of control. Here you got
through it by a few ticks. Here you came
up within a couple of ticks. Here you're
well below. Here you're within probably
about four or five ticks. Here you got
within one tick.
Right? So, it's it's not a a pure sense
that it's going to trade right back to
that level and go down, you know.
It's an area, right? It's an area and
often times it's going to keep you on
the right side of the trade by you
understanding if you're short on this
high, right? If you're short off the
second bar, okay, I know the point of
control is coming in here around 37.
You know, the next bar opens up, doesn't
come up, doesn't test that level, starts
trading below. Okay, the next bar was
stays below the previous bar's point of
control, right? This is an area where if
you're trailing a stop, you can hide
behind.
Okay?
Cuz it's going to give you a clue on
where the bar can trade back to. Here's
a market, right? Point of control is
acting as support on the way up.
On the way down it's acting as
resistance. You can see here it came
within one tick. Here it got through it
by three ticks. Here it came right to
it. To the tick here.
Got within two ticks on the way back
down. These two bars traded, you know,
two ticks above it. This one shot a
little bit up.
Here you trade right to it. Here you
trade, you know, three ticks through.
Here you trade one tick past it, but
it's going to help tell you an area
where a trade where the market can trade
back to.
Okay?
It'd be like
Uh
I used to call it like Jack and the
Beanstalk, right? Like
you know, it's it magic beans, you know,
knowing
an area where the market can potentially
retrace back to in the bar that you're
in.
Okay? On the way down, point of control
is acting as resistance. Here it got
within two ticks. Here it got within
three ticks. Here it got within three
ticks. You put in your bottom, starts
rallying back up.
Comes back down to that level. Here
we're still above it. Comes back
one tick past that point of control.
Here, well, the point of control is up
here, but here we trade below it.
This next bar, right to that point of
control. This next bar gets within
three ticks past this point of control.
So, now on the way up, it's acting as
support.
Now,
seeing the price level where the most
volume traded is all well and good, but
you want to apply it to your trading.
And as I showed you earlier,
point of control can act as stopping
volume for reversals.
But,
now I want you to think outside the box
and take it to another level, okay? One
point of control is good.
But, what if you can see some more, the
next two levels, the next two point of
controls, the next two high volume areas
in a bar?
Once you start seeing bunches of point
of controls, including the second and
third point of control levels, you know,
that's market generated information at
your best. And in the Orderflows Trader,
we allow you to do that. You can see
here, you can expand point of control
two, point of control three. You could
set them up so you can see the next two
levels. And there are several ways you
can use the three points of controls
together. The first level is to find
areas where each bar's point of control
group is sort of bunched together with
the bars around it. This is indicative
of an extended value area forming.
And if we start trading above or below
that, you go in that direction as it's
going to offer near-term support or
resistance. And then more importantly,
when the market starts trading back to
that level, watch what happens. Is it
support or is it becoming Is it breaking
through?
I mean, is it going to be a resistance
area or is it going to be a support
area, right? This is you know, this is
basic
trading 101, right? Support becomes
resistance, right? Here's your
resistance, okay? And you're forming you
know, basically just migrating lower, a
little bit lower each bunch. You know,
normally you'll see point of controls
sort of spread out in each bar. But,
when you see them sort of grouped
together like that, it's telling you
there's resistance here.
Right? This area, there's strong
sellers. Okay? Now, later when you come
back up through it, you got to be paying
attention. Right? We came back up to it
a little bit later, and we came off
about three or four ticks uh points.
Then we came back up.
It was struggling here, and then boom,
it popped up. Aggressive buying came in,
and someone
just triggered whatever stops there were
here, or someone swept through that
market. That's you see this big um
stacked buying and balance here as you
go higher. Now, this area that was your
resistance is now your support area.
Okay?
So, another example, right?
You have these points controls, these
groups.
Three point of controls stacked point of
controls stacked on top of each other,
but they're all coming in around the
same area in here, right? See in this
box here.
Okay? We sell off, right? You see even
the third you know, as we come outside
the box, comes in here, and it sells
off. Okay? Starts selling off, comes
back up in here.
Starts gets through it. Right? Now, what
was your resistance becomes your
support. Comes back in here, tests it.
Goes back up.
Right? Like I said, you know, trading
you just because you adopt point of you
know, order flow doesn't mean you have
to abandon all your other styles of
trading. You can you still use you know,
basic support and resistance rules. You
know, another way is to use three points
of controls look for groups of them
migrating higher or lower. And what that
is, it's an indication of value moving
higher or lower. So, like I said, you
know, generally
points of controls aren't always bunched
together, right? You know, they'll be a
little bit spread out, right? If you're
looking at three of them. You know, you
see it appear point of control one
will appear somewhere, then the second
and third
can appear anywhere. You know, it really
depends on the bar. But, when you see
sort of them bunched together like this
high, it's bunched together up here.
Next bar, it's bunched together. Next
bar, it's bunched together. These tight
bars,
value is moving lower, right? And boom,
the market sells off.
This one over here,
you know, you got two that are sort of
bunched together even though one is
separated, and then a higher bunch. So,
that one's a bit borderline. Now,
here you have
bunch point of control, bunch point of
control, bunch point of control, bunch
point of control, all moving lower.
What do you think's happening there?
There's big seller here. Big sellers
here. Big sellers here. Big sellers
here. And why? Not only are they
offering it up, but they're hitting the
bids,
right? That's what's causing
the heavy volume in those areas, and
it's all happening in very congested
areas.
Here's another one.
Points of control. This first one again
is one tick separates. If people ask,
"Well, can you accept that or not?"
Well,
I'd have to put it in context, you know,
there's there's I don't want to
put down a rule saying, "Well, it could
only be when they're stacked on top of
each other, and if you have one that's
not stacked on top of each other like
this one, it invalidates the whole
thing."
But when I see three stacked on each
other, it's good enough. Um even if I
have one that's not stacked, I'd be
willing to accept it. You know,
sometimes people like to draw hard and
fast rules, and it sort of goes back to,
you know, I think their training, you
know, programmers and and engineers try
to find exactness in everything, and
sometimes, you know, you got to bend a
little bit, right? But this one does
have three stacked here in a row.
I would take this one as the fourth one.
And you see how the market moves higher.
So,
point of control represents value in a
bar, right? Understanding where value is
right now in the bar,
your trading is an extremely valuable
piece of information, and
don't overcomplicate trading, right?
I've just showed you how applying common
sense to the markets
can help you in your trading, right? But
you have to have the right tools, right?
For me, that tool is order flow.
Just simply looking at a chart. You
know, I've looked at a chart long enough
that I can just know pick up these
things, but for most people, they need a
way of learning it, all right? And
you know, most people Well, now that we
have a lockdown, you know,
the fortunate thing of the lockdown is
you got a lot of time on your hands to
study, study the markets. Don't make
trading more complicated than it needs
to be, right? Anyone could look at order
flow just as anyone could look at a
normal bar candlestick chart. The key is
knowing what to look for
and what it means. So, if you're you're
interested in learning more about order
flow,
go to orderflows.com/of2
.html. Okay, I've got a very special
deal for everybody and
it's
basically, it's it's the software, but
not just the software, right? Having
software is one thing, right? You want
to know how to use it. You want to get
the most out of it, all right? Just as
if you um buy a car, right? You want to
get the most out of a car, you want to
know how the seats go down so you can
create more space in the back, you know,
everything. And for a limited time,
right? I know we're on this, you know,
it it's a it's a bad time for
a lot of people. Um for people that
haven't saved, for those that have
saved, you know, they're going to be
able to weather the storm or you know,
if you
if you have a job and
are confident you're going to
keep it and you get out of this, you
know, much better. Now this is the time
to improve yourself, right? Learn how to
become a trader, not just follow signals
blindly back and forth. Oh, this one is
green, so I got to buy. This is red, so
I got to sell. Learn how to become a
trader. Learn how to read what's
happening in the market. So, for a
special time, I'm going to give you
the Order Flows Trader software, which
normally is $899. I'm going to give you
my Order Flows Trading Course, which is
normally $297, and access to my Inner
Circle video series, which is
a series of 56 videos, advanced training
on order flow.
Right? Normally, if you were to get all
this separately, it's going to cost you
around $1,500, but
I got a special deal for you. It's just
$675 right now. So, really, the only
risk that you're going to have
is losing this discounted one-time
price, cuz normally I sell it at a
higher price, honestly. I sell this
package at at at a higher price than
$675. I sell it um
around $800.
You're going to waste a year of your
time,
over a year of your time trying to do
this alone, try to figure out the
markets by yourself. And honestly, what
you learn in the markets now and you
apply it a year from now, hopefully when
the markets are settled down, it's
probably going to be a little bit
different. And the ability to understand
order flow in a few weeks versus never.
So, you know, other traders, you know,
Sheila was was new to trading. She got
my Order Flows Trader software. She
wrote this about it, you know, "My Order
Flows Trader's Your Order Flows Trader
software is remarkably helpful, because
now I can clearly see
what's really happening in the market.
Like, for example, who's in control of
the market on a very specific time, and
who's getting weaker as well."
So,
who here agrees with me that now is the
best time to start with order flow? You
know, there's the old saying, "The best
time to plant a tree was 20 years ago,
but the second best time to plant a tree
is today."
Right? So,
you know, ask yourself where you want to
be a year from now. Ask yourself where
you want to be when we come out of this
um coronavirus
stuff.
Um you know, so you you got choices,
honestly. You could go at it alone,
spend thousands and thousands of dollars
figuring out order flow, how to
understand the markets, get frustrated,
and potentially waste years of your
life, right? Or you could learn order
flow from someone who has traded with it
for over 20 years at some of the biggest
trading firms in the world. You know,
when I was a kid, I used to collect
baseball cards, okay? This is how I like
to describe order flow to people. And on
the back of a baseball card, it would
have basic information, your
the player's at bats, the number of
hits, you know, the second, you know,
the doubles, triples, the home runs, the
RBIs, and his batting average, right?
That's what people most of us grew up
you know, looking just at that
information. Now you look at a baseball
card, it's got all this other analytical
stuff, you know, it has obviously, you
know, the at bats, the hits, the home
runs, um
doubles, triples, home runs.
But now it's got, you know, the slugging
percentage, right? It's got the on base
plus slugging percentage. It's got
obviously their average, but it's got
the wins above replacement. These are
all advanced analytics,
right? And because, you know, people are
realizing that you can take this data,
what you're seeing here,
and you can
get other pieces of data out of it. All
right, I don't want to get into a
baseball analytics here, but it's
basically the difference between looking
at a normal chart and a footprint chart.
All right, so
if you're a beginner, you can learn
order flow step by step and get software
that's easy to use and understand the
market with. If you are a veteran to
trading,
you'll be able to improve your trading
by finding better entries and exits as
you get a firmer grasp on what's
happening in the markets right now. Now
as a special bonus, right, if you get
this, I just decided this today, and
again, after the special goes away,
it's not going to be included, but
I'm going to give you access to my order
flow playbook, right? And it's it's a
mini course. There's about There's 10
trade setups in there that you can apply
for your trading. You know, I've created
several courses, but I I find honestly
the order flow playbook I think is is
my favorite.
Okay, and again, to get started, go to
orderflows.com/off2.
I put the link in the chat there.
And it's going to take you to this page,
okay?
You can see I just updated this the
other day, March 26th. There's a video
There's a few videos. I think there's
one or two videos on there, you know,
introduction to the order flows trading.
Scroll down to the bottom of the page,
okay? Take a seat here. You can see the
one-time payment
$675.
You just click on the button, okay? You
can pay with PayPal, Visa, American
Express, whatever.
And it takes you to the page. It's
processed by PayPal, right? So, if you
have a PayPal account, most people do,
you can just enter your email or phone
number there and click next. Or if you
don't have an account, you can still pay
with
a debit or credit card by clicking on
down here where it says pay with debit
or credit card.
So, you know, for those that have stuck
around, I've gone a bit longer than
I didn't know how long I'd go. I thought
I'd go about an hour. It's about an hour
and 20 minutes. If you want my book, you
know, the book that I started writing in
in
I don't want to say 2013 cuz that's the
year I left JP Morgan and I had a
one-year non-compete um
clause where basically they said
anything you do over the next year we
got rights to. Started in uh 2014.
Trading Order Flow
is a 150-page book. Just go to
orderflows.com/book
.html. Enter your name and email
address, click submit. After you hit
submit, it will take you to the download
immediately. So, it won't be sent to
your email later.
It will be available immediately after
you hit submit.
So,
um I'm going to check to if there's any
questions.
First, just give me a second.
Let me just find my question area.
Let me put that there for you guys.
Uh, let's see if questions.
There's
Let me expand this.
Will it work with up tick down tick data
feeds like e-signal?
Um, no. It doesn't use up tick down
tick. It uses
Um, as you keeps the data in tracking on
NinjaTrader, they upgraded when they
made NinjaTrader 8, they upgraded the
way data is handled. Before in the past,
you needed to
basically keep your charts running so
you'd have accurate data. Some people
sort of got around it by using up tick
down tick, but we find for order flow,
if you want the pure
the best available information,
save the data. You know, get a you know,
you can get trading clouds, um, you
know, VPS, VPNs for, you know, there's
some that are like $60 a month or
something. Get that, run your trading
software on there. You know, cuz people
I say, "Can I use Order Flow Trader on
more than one computer?"
No, you can't because it's tied to
NinjaTrader's machine ID on a specific
machine.
What I recommend is as opposed to buying
two copies,
just get a, um, VPS or a VPN
and, you know, for $40 a month, $50 a
month, put your trading software on
there.
And it will automatically run 24/7.
And it'll have the data for you, right?
And you can log in from your PC at home,
can log in your PC at work. If you go on
the road, you go on a trip, you can
still log into that. Okay? That's sort
of the way of the future, I think, with
computing.
Um
Let me see.
Do not use NinjaTrader, use thinkorswim
and Schwab. Any suggestions? Yes.
You know, for people that don't want to
use a NinjaTrader brokerage, okay? If
you If you trade futures, I I
you know, NinjaTrader now, they've
in the past, you know, up until I forgot
what year it was,
2013 or something, you used to be able
to use NinjaTrader with any broker out
there, but then they they changed the
format and they made deals with certain
brokerage firms, you know, it's like
NinjaTrader brokerage, obviously, when
they started that up. Um
Interactive Broker, I think Gain or
something, and and a and a few others.
This is very limited. Um what people do
is they will get the software, they'll
get the free version of NinjaTrader, it
will run on the free version,
and they just use the free version of
NinjaTrader, but you do need a live
quote feed. So,
the
the the simple way to do it is open a
small account with NinjaTrader, you
know, to trade micros. You could put in
300 dollars or something in there, but
you'll get the data feed for like 15
dollars
as opposed to going out to like, say,
Kinetic and getting a real-time feed,
you'll be paying monthly,
you know, 150 dollars. So, after 2
months,
you know, you're basically spending 300
dollars that you could fund an account
with. Um but you're going to trade the
futures through your thinkorswim
platform or through your Schwab
platform.
Um someone asked, can I get the book
only? Yes, you can.
Now,
this package here, okay?
These are the two bonuses and the order
flow playbook.
This package doesn't include the
indicators. On my website,
I have these three pieces plus two
additional indicators on a different
deal.
That different deal is much more. It's
almost double the price of this. It's
It's 1250. That includes two indicators,
which those two indicators
sell for a total of
One's 500, one's 350, I think.
So, that's an additional $850 for those
two indicators.
But, if you want to really get started
using order flow and the indicator
package that I have on my website,
will help you see things in the order
flow that you I didn't talk about today.
There's There's many different setups in
order flow that you can look at, but
sometimes for some people having an
indicator sort of gives it helps them
jump-start their trading
into order flow.
Um but, there's you know, every trader's
different. Some people like indicators
to give them, you know, some help in
identifying trading opportunities. But,
if you're sticking if you just want to
learn the basics of order flow, get
started with order flow, watching these
courses
plus the order flow playbook,
learn a few setups, just look for those
setups, and go from there. You know, I I
know a lot of people like to automate
things cuz there are softwares out there
like um
Pablo's uh markers, which you can
automate
some trading setups. That's fine. You
can do that with my indicators.
But, I always like to tell people, you
know,
especially now, you know, for for some
people, you know, they're a bit worried,
you know, this coronavirus. You don't
know if you're going to have a job or
not for some people, honestly. Um not
trying to sugarcoat it, but
the the whole thing is
being able to
get started, right? The The worst thing
you could do is is is not get started.
So, I tried to lower
the barrier
of entry for a lot of people. Now, if
you get my software,
you know, and you want to add on the
additional indicators that are in the
other package that's on the website,
email me. You know, I work with people
all the time on on
you know, special deals cuz I realize,
you know, everybody
is
on a different um
level, okay?
I don't think he is Someone asks, uh you
know, the link doesn't take you to the
right page. You got to
book .html in it.
Um you know, but another question that
comes up quite often is, you know, can I
use it on Forex or equities? Yeah, you
can. Um problem with Forex
but
is the data is not, you know,
centralized the way futures are. Um
so, you know, you could be trading on a
on a Forex platform and they're getting
their date, you know, that basically
it's probably a white label from
Barclays, but, you know, the data feed
that you're you're looking at versus the
data feed that you're trading on can be
different, right? Especially if you're
getting it from, say, you know, eSignal
or, you know, Kinetic or
um IQ feed. You know, you got to look at
where the data signal is coming from.
You know, a lot of these Forex brokers
are basically white labels of a bank,
okay? And their data might not be going
into that data feed or the data feed
could be aggregated. The nice thing
about futures is it's centralized. It
comes from the exchange, right? And all
the trades go through that exchange.
It's not going through a particular bank
or particular brokerage company.
Um
let's just go through a couple more
questions. Will this work on
TradeStation?
Well, or Sierra Charts, you know,
there's there's
there's versions of
My software won't. It'll work on Ninja
Trader. Um
there are footprint charts available for
those other um software platforms.
Um Pavel is interested in the flow
trader indicator. I'll email you on
that. That's a separate indicator.
Um Manuel is asking about
this order flow playbook. Find it here.
This one.
It's you know, it's course I came up
with uh I released last summer.
It's it's a nice course. It said it's
about uh
seven or eight modules, but I I I talk
about eight or 10 different uh
trading setups. Again, you know, it's
you got to know what to look for in the
order flow, otherwise it's pointless to
look at order flow. You know, that's
what I scratch my head with a lot of
people that trade on a dome,
but they don't have the education,
right? They don't know what to look for.
So, what do you know, they say, "We'll
spend 10,000 hours looking at a dome."
Well, God, I I'd I'd bang my head
against the wall
cuz I spent 10,000 hours I spent a lot
more than 10,000 hours staring at a
dome, and I'll tell you
it's
you know, there's a lot more of the
things I'd rather do in life. And the
problem with looking at something like a
dome
is especially now in this day and age of
uh
you know, phones or something you you'll
look away from a dome for 5 seconds and
you miss everything.
Okay, the the nice thing about a
footprint chart is the information is
there for you. So, you know, it it gives
you
sort of a
a macro view of the order flow.
Um
Bloodhound, well, the footprint chart is
not available with Bloodhound, but the
indicators that I saw on my website are
general.
Um
Let me let's So, I don't like will you
answer email questions? I've sent you
various emails in the past. You've never
answered from an anonymous guy.
I don't know, you know, I've I've
answered
I I do get a lot of questions um that I
do answer. But, uh
Let me see. There will be a recording.
So, yes.
You know, this what is it drives me wild
is is sometimes you know, someone will
post something on my YouTube channel
like a question.
But, they'll say, "Hey, I sent you an
email." But, they're
Yeah, cuz sometimes you know, I got spam
filters on my email sometimes and you
know, honestly, sometimes people got
some very strange emails. You know, big
booty 62 is going to get filtered out,
you know, and if someone's posted on my
YouTube, "I sent you an email." And they
don't put a clue into who is it from,
I'm not going to know, you know, because
I do get emails that are
go into the spam folder. You know, I do
try to go through the spam folder, but
sometimes I miss things, okay? So, just
just bear that in mind. Manuel, I'm
going to try to give you a call this
weekend. I just been very busy this
these last few days.
Um
So, anyway, guys,
uh what are the difference Okay, just
really
quickly.
Um
Pulse, turns, Delta Scalper. You know,
I've I've got a bunch of indicators.
I'll probably be launching a new website
with indicators.
Um
Yeah, my programmer he's also
has a lot of work on his ebooks. I give
him a lot of stuff to program,
especially in this downtime. Um
But, that you know, my indicators don't
overlap each other. So, I have like the
pulse
and the turns which come with the
package that's available on my website.
And
the Delta Scalper, Price Rejector, um
they they look at different things in
the order flow, right? I just showed you
five different ways on this presentation
to look at order flow. You You the pulse
is something that
tells you when
aggressive activity is picking up. You
know, when somebody is coming in and
potentially sweeping the market, you
know, either buying, lifting all the
offers, or hitting all the bids, or, you
know,
basically buying it up through certain
levels.
Um the turns is a different one. The
turns
The turns actually used to be a
different indicator called the S&R
levels. We've renamed it to the turns.
Um
part of it because the guy that
originally did the turns or did the S&R
levels is a different programmer than my
regular programmer, and I made a few
changes to it
that in my opinion made it better.
So, I just decided to change the name to
the turns because it's finding turning
points in the market, right? It's
finding areas where there's supportive
volume or resistance selling in the
market. So, it's it's looking for um
basically turning points in the market.
That's why it's called the turns. The
Delta Scalper
uh showed you earlier, the first thing I
showed you on this presentation is
basically the Delta Surge, which is you
can download for free on my website.
But, the Delta Scalper is a different
way to analyze Delta. It's
it's looking for quick hits in the Delta
based on the reading of current Delta
versus
Delta in the immediate past.
So, it's different. Price Rejector is
also different. It's looking for signs
of price
um rejection
at swing highs and swing lows, right? I
showed you the small digit prints.
That's a very
particular thing in the order flow.
That's just looking for prints. You
know, it's a simple thing, right? You
don't need my software to look for small
prints. If you have
a you know, another company's software
or footprint chart, you can look for
that.
Okay, but the
Price Rejector
isn't based on that. Um it it looks for
price rejection by reading the order
flow in the bar.
So, anyway, guys, I'll end it there Um
for you guys right now.
And you know, again, thanks for spending
your
Saturday afternoon. You know, it's uh
It's a strange time that we're in, you
know, with the markets and you know,
obviously, people's health. So, stay
healthy. You know, don't lick any uh
Don't lick anything outside like you see
these idiots doing out there. I
I don't know what goes through some
people's heads. But again, you know,
stay uh stay healthy
and stay active. You know, with me, I've
been doing some exercises. You know, I I
find myself eating a lot more being on
lockdown that I've I had to get the
exercise bike and bring it inside the
house
to uh
to start riding 10 miles a day at least.
So, anyway, guys, stay healthy, stay
safe, and
I'll catch you guys later. Thanks for
spending your afternoon with me.